Soy etnobotánico;
un científico que trabaja en la selva
documentando el uso que la gente le da a las plantas autóctonas.
Hago esto desde hace mucho tiempo
y quiero decirles
que esta gente conoce los bosques y estos tesoros medicinales
mejor que Uds. o yo.
Pero además, estas culturas,
las culturas indígenas,
están desapareciendo mucho más rápido que los propios bosques.
La principal especie en peligro de extinción
en la selva Amazónica
no es el jaguar,
no es el águila arpía,
sino los tribus aisladas y remotas.
Hace ahora 4 años, me lesioné el pie en un accidente de escalada
y fui al médico.
Me recetó compresas calientes,
compresas frías, aspirinas,
analgésicos, anti-inflamatorios,
inyecciones de cortisona.
No funcionó.
Varios meses después,
estaba en el noreste del Amazonas,
entré en una aldea,
el chamán me dijo: "Estás cojeando",
y nunca olvidaré esto mientras viva.
Me miró a la cara y me dijo:
"Quítate el zapato y dame el machete".
(Risas)
Se acercó a una palmera,
cortó un helecho,
lo tiró en el fuego,
me lo aplicó en el pie,
lo tiró en una olla con agua,
y me hizo beber el té.
El dolor desapareció durante 7 meses.
Cuando volvió a dolerme, me fui a ver al chamán de nuevo.
Me hizo lo mismo,
y llevo 3 años curado.
¿Por quién prefieren ser atendidos?
(Aplausos)
Ahora, no nos engañemos, la medicina occidental
es el sistema sanitario de más éxito en la historia,
pero tiene muchas deficiencias.
¿Dónde está la cura para el cáncer de mama?
¿Para la esquizofrenia?
¿Dónde está la cura para el reflujo gastroesofágico?
¿Dónde está la cura para el insomnio?
El hecho es que esta gente
a veces puede, a veces, a veces,
sanar cosas que nosotros no podemos.
Aquí vemos a un curandero del noreste del Amazonas
tratando la leishmaniosis,
una enfermedad parasitaria realmente desagradable
que aflige a 12 millones de personas en todo el mundo.
El tratamiento en occidente consiste en inyecciones de antimonio.
Duele, es caro,
y probablemente no es bueno para el corazón;
es un metal pesado.
Este hombre lo cura con 3 plantas de la selva amazónica.
Esta es la rana mágica.
Mi gran colega, Loren McIntyre, ya fallecido,
descubrió la fuente del Amazonas
la laguna McIntyre en los Andes peruanos,
se perdió en la frontera entre Perú y Brasil, hace 30 años.
Fue rescatado por un grupo de indígenas aislados llamados matsés.
Le dejaron señas para que las siguiera en el bosque, lo cual hizo.
Luego, sacaron unas cestas de hojas de palma.
Y, de ellas, sacaron estas ranas mono verdes
--son grandes los bichos, así de grandes--
y empezaron a lamerlas.
Resulta que son extremadamente alucinógenas.
McIntyre escribió sobre eso y el editor de la revista High Times leyó sus palabras;
ya ven que los etnobotánicos tienen amigos en todo tipo de culturas extrañas.
(Risas)
Y el hombre decidió irse al Amazonas y probarlo; lo hizo y después escribió:
"Mi presión arterial se disparó,
perdí el control de todo mi cuerpo,
me desmayé en un rincón,
me desperté en una hamaca 6 horas más tarde,
y me sentí como Dios durante 2 días".
(Risas)
Un químico italiano leyó esto y dijo:
"No me interesan para nada los aspectos teológicos de la rana mono verde.
¿Pero qué es esto de la variación de la presión arterial?"
Hablamos de un químico italiano que está trabajando
en un nuevo tratamiento para la hipertensión
basado en los péptidos de la piel de la rana mono verde,
y de otros científicos que están buscando
una cura para el estafilococo dorado, resistente a los medicamentos.
Qué ironía si estos indígenas aislados con su rana mágica
resultan ser una de las curas.
Este es un chamán ayahuasca
del noroeste del Amazonas, en medio de la ceremonia de yagé.
Lo llevé a Los Ángeles para reunirse con un empleado de una fundación
en busca de fondos para proteger su cultura.
El hombre miró al curandero y le dijo:
"Ud. no estudió medicina, ¿verdad?"
El chamán respondió: "No".
"Bueno, entonces, ¿qué puede saber acerca de sanidad?"
El chamán le miró y dijo:
"Ud. sabe que si tiene una infección, hay que ir al médico,
pero muchas enfermedades humanas son males
del corazón, la mente y el espíritu.
La medicina occidental no puede curarlos. Yo los trato".
(Aplausos)
Pero no todo es color de rosa a la hora de aprender
sobre nuevos medicamentos a partir de la naturaleza.
Esta es una víbora de Brasil,
cuyo veneno se estudió en la Universidade de São Paulo.
Más tarde, se fabricaron inhibidores ECA,
un tratamiento de vanguardia para la hipertensión.
La hipertensión es la causa de más del 10 %
de todas las muertes diarias en el mundo.
Se trata de una industria de USD 4000 millones
basada en el veneno de una víbora brasileña,
y los brasileños no recibieron un centavo.
Esta no es una manera aceptable de hacer negocios.
A la selva tropical se la llama: "máxima expresión de la vida terrestre".
Hay un dicho en Surinam que me gusta mucho:
"Las selvas tropicales aguardan respuestas
a las preguntas que todavía tenemos que hacer".
Pero como todos Uds. saben, está desapareciendo rápidamente.
Aquí en Brasil, en el Amazonas, en todo el mundo.
Tomé esta foto de un pequeño avión
al sobrevolar la frontera oriental de la reserva indígena xingú,
en el estado de Mato Grosso al noroeste de aquí.
En la mitad superior de la imagen, se ve dónde viven los indígenas.
La línea del medio es la frontera oriental de la reserva.
En la mitad superior están los indígenas, en la mitad inferior están los blancos.
Arriba, los medicamentos milagrosos,
abajo, solo un montón de vacas flacas.
Arriba, el carbono queda capturado en el bosque, donde pertenece,
abajo, el carbono es liberado en la atmósfera
donde provoca el cambio climático.
De hecho, la segunda causa por la cual el carbono se libera en la atmósfera
es la destrucción del bosque.
Pero cuando hablamos de la destrucción es importante tener en cuenta
que el Amazonas es el paisaje más poderoso de todos.
Es un lugar lleno de belleza y maravillas.
El oso hormiguero más grande del mundo vive en la selva tropical,
y puede pesar hasta 40 kg.
La tarántula Goliat o araña come pájaros
es la araña más grande del mundo.
Se encuentra en el Amazonas también.
La envergadura de las alas del águila arpía tiene más de 2 metros.
Y el caimán negro...
este monstruo puede llegar a pesar más de media tonelada.
Son conocidos por ser devoradores de hombres.
La anaconda, la serpiente más grande,
el capibara, el roedor más grande.
Una ejemplar de aquí, de Brasil, llegó a 91 kg.
Veamos dónde viven estas criaturas,
visitemos el noreste del Amazonas,
el hogar de la tribu akuriyo.
Los pueblos aislados juegan un papel místico e icónico
en nuestra imaginación.
Son los que mejor conocen la naturaleza.
Son los que realmente viven en total armonía con la naturaleza.
Según nuestros estándares, a algunos se les calificaría como pueblos primitivos.
"No conocían el fuego, por lo menos cuando se les contactó por primera vez".
Pero conocen el bosque mucho mejor que nosotros.
Las akuriyos tienen 35 palabras para la miel,
y otros indígenas los catalogan
como los verdaderos maestros de la tierra-esmeralda.
Esta es la cara de mi amigo, Pohnay.
Cuando yo era adolescente y escuchaba a los Rolling Stones en Nueva Orleans,
Pohnay era un nómada del bosque,
vagando por el noreste de la selva amazónica
con un pequeño grupo, en busca de venado, plantas medicinales
y de una esposa entre los otros pequeños grupos nómadas.
Pero es la gente como él, que sabe cosas que nosotros no sabemos,
y tienen mucho que enseñarnos.
Pero si uno entra en la mayoría de los bosques del Amazonas,
no hay pueblos indígenas.
Esto es lo que encontrarán: tallas en rocas
que estos pueblos indígenas, estos pueblos no contactados,
han dejado al afilar sus hachas.
Estas culturas que antaño bailaron, hicieron el amor, cantaron a sus dioses,
y adoraron al bosque,
todo lo que queda de ellos es una marca en la piedra, como la que Uds. ven aquí.
Vamos al oeste de la Amazonia,
que es el epicentro de los pueblos aislados.
Cada uno de estos puntos representa un pequeño pueblo indígena aislado,
y hoy, la gran noticia es que creemos que hay 14 o 15 grupos aislados
solo en la Amazonia colombiana.
¿Por qué esta gente está aislada?
Saben que existimos, que hay un mundo exterior.
Es una forma de resistencia.
Han optado por permanecer aislados, y creo que es su derecho seguir estándolo.
¿Por qué se esconden estas tribus de los hombres?
He aquí por qué.
Obviamente, esto empezó en 1492.
Pero a finales del siglo pasado el detonante fue el comercio del caucho.
La demanda de caucho natural, que venía de la Amazonia,
fue el equivalente botánico a la fiebre del oro.
Caucho para neumáticos de bicicleta,
para neumáticos de automóviles,
goma para zepelines.
La loca carrera por conseguir el caucho fue la razón,
y el hombre de la izquierda, Julio Arana,
uno de los verdaderos villanos de la historia.
Su gente, su empresa, y otras compañías como la suya
mataron, masacraron, torturaron y exterminaron
a los indígenas como Witoto que ven a la derecha de la foto.
Aún hoy, cuando salen de la selva, rara vez la historia tiene un final feliz.
Estos son nukaks. Fueron contactados en los años 80.
Un año después, los mayores de 40 habían muerto.
Y recuerden, son sociedades ágrafas.
Los ancianos son las bibliotecas.
Cada vez que muere un chamán,
es como si una biblioteca se hubiera incendiado.
Se han visto obligados a abandonar sus tierras.
Los narcotraficantes se han apoderado de las tierras nukak,
y los nukaks viven como mendigos
en parques públicos al este de Colombia.
Desde las tierras nukak, los quiero llevar al suroeste,
a uno de los paisajes más espectaculares del mundo:
el Parque Nacional Chiribiquete.
Alrededor de él, vivían 3 tribus aisladas
y gracias al gobierno colombiano y a los colegas colombianos,
sigue creciendo.
Es más grande que el estado de Maryland.
Es un tesoro importante de diversidad botánica.
Fue explorado botánicamente por primera vez en 1943
por mi mentor, Richard Schultes,
lo pueden ver aquí en la cima de la montaña Bell,
la montaña sagrada de los karijonas.
Les mostraré cómo se ve ahora.
Al sobrevolar Chiribiquete,
podemos ver que las montañas aún están perdidas,
ningún científico ha subido a la cima.
De hecho, nadie ha vuelto a subir a la cima de la montaña Bell
desde Schultes en el año 1943.
Les llevaré hasta aquí en la montaña Bell justo al este de la imagen.
Les enseñaré cómo se ve hoy en día.
Esto no es solo un tesoro de diversidad botánica,
no solo es el hogar de 3 tribus aisladas,
también es el mayor tesoro de arte precolombino en el mundo:
más de 200 000 pinturas.
El científico holandés Thomas van der Hammen
la describió como la Capilla Sixtina de la selva amazónica.
Pero pasemos de Chiribiquete al sureste, de nuevo en la Amazonia colombiana.
Recuerden, la Amazonia colombiana es más grande que Nueva Inglaterra.
La selva amazónica es enorme,
y Brasil tiene una gran parte, pero no toda ella.
Vamos a dos parques nacionales, Cahuinari y Puré,
en la Amazonia colombiana
—-esta es la frontera con Brasil a la derecha—-
hogar de varios grupos de pueblos aislados y no contactados.
Los conocedores pueden observar los techos de estas malocas,
estas casas comunales,
y ver que hay diversidad cultural.
Estas son, de hecho, tribus diferentes.
Así aisladas como están,
les mostraré cómo el mundo exterior les está invadiendo:
Aquí vemos un aumento del comercio y del transporte en el Putumayo.
Al apaciguarse la guerra civil en Colombia,
el mundo exterior empieza a notarse.
Al norte, tenemos explotaciones ilegales de oro,
también al este, en Brasil.
Se ha incrementado la caza y la pesca con fines comerciales.
Vemos talas ilegal de madera al sur
y narcotraficantes que tratan de usar el parque para entrar en Brasil.
Y esta es la razón por la cual, en el pasado,
no había que meterse con los indígenas aislados.
Y si parece que la foto es borrosa es porque fue tomada de prisa, y el motivo
(Risas)
Esto parece... (Aplausos)
Esto parece un hangar de la Amazonia brasileña,
pero se trata de una exposición de arte en La Habana, Cuba
por parte de un grupo llamado Los Carpinteros.
Esta es su percepción del porqué no debemos meternos con los indígenas.
Pero el mundo está cambiando.
Estos son los mashco-piros en la frontera entre Brasil y Perú
que han huido de la selva
porque fueron esencialmente expulsados por los narcotraficantes y leñadores.
Y en Perú, hay un negocio de muy dudosa legalidad;
los llamamos safaris humanos.
Se visita grupos aislados para tomarles una foto.
Por supuesto, cuando uno les da ropa y herramientas,
también le regala enfermedades.
Los llamamos "safaris inhumanos".
Estos son indígenas en la frontera de Perú que fueron sobrevolados por los misioneros
que quieren ir para convertirlos al cristianismo.
Sabemos cómo acaba esto.
¿Qué hacer?
Introducir tecnología en las tribus contactadas,
no en los pueblos indígenas aislados,
de manera respetuosa con su cultura.
Este es el matrimonio perfecto
de la antigua sabiduría chamánica y la tecnología del siglo XXI.
Lo hemos hecho hasta ahora con más de 30 tribus,
hemos cartografiado, gestionado y ofrecido una mayor protección
a más de 70 millones de hectáreas de selva tropical ancestral.
(Aplausos)
Esto permite a los indígenas controlar su entorno y su destino cultural.
También se establecieron casetas de vigilancia para alejar a los extraños.
Estos son indígenas, entrenados como guardaparques indígenas,
que patrullan las fronteras y mantienen al resto del mundo a distancia.
Esta es una foto de un contacto real.
Estos son indígenas chitonahua en la frontera entre Brasil y Perú.
Salieron de la selva en busca de ayuda.
Les dispararon, y sus malocas, sus casas comunales fueron quemadas.
Algunos de ellos fueron masacrados.
El uso de armas automáticas para masacrar a la gente no contactada
es uno de los abusos más viles y repugnantes en contra de los derechos humanos
que hay en nuestro planeta en este momento y tiene que parar.
(Aplausos)
Pero permítanme concluir diciendo
que este trabajo puede ser gratificante desde un punto de vista espiritual,
pero es difícil y puede ser peligroso.
Dos colegas míos fallecieron recientemente al estrellarse con una avioneta.
Ayudaban en el bosque protegiendo a esos pueblos indígenas no contactados.
Así que, en conclusión, la pregunta es: ¿cómo será el futuro?
Este es el pueblo uray en Brasil.
¿Qué depara el futuro para ellos, y que depara el futuro para nosotros?
Pensemos de manera diferente.
Hagamos un mundo mejor.
Si el clima va a cambiar, vamos a hacer de ello algo para mejor y no para peor.
Vivamos en un planeta lleno de vegetación exuberante,
donde los pueblos aislados puedan permanecer no contactados,
manteniendo ese misterio y ese conocimiento si así lo deciden.
Vivimos en un mundo donde los chamanes
puedan vivir en estos bosques para sanarse a sí mismos y a nosotros
con sus plantas místicas y sus ranas sagradas.
Gracias de nuevo.
(Aplausos)